the return of the ghost bar at Palms
Casino Resort is Now official do you
have any memories I do at the ghost bar
absolutely yeah can you share them no no
no no other one you can share you know
how crazy I am I do that's what I said
not at all the legendary nightclub
reopened its doors last night and JC
Fernandez was high Atop The 55th floor
of the Palms to capture the moment
Crystal congratulations ghost bar is
back here at the Palms how does it feel
oh it feels so amazing from the day that
we opened even before then there was a
lot of anticipation that was building
and it was the number one question we
were asked when is Ghost bar opening is
it reopening and now we're here I have
just myself I have so many personal
memories inside ghostbar and I think so
many people do that's the past what is
the future hold for the most part gosh
there's just so much right you got this
view which we're standing out here you
know what wasn't here previously was
Allegiant Stadium right here to our side
yes so the skyline's changed a bit Yeah
so we want to make sure that there's
energy inside and outside you know we're
looking at different entertainment
offerings as well that will you know
change the energy and the vibe a little
bit you know different times of the
night and then the cocktail program is
just out of sight so it's really steeped
in the whole ghost bar theme and so
we've got you know large party formats
so you can hit a Kegerator if you got a
big group
exactly you have flights you know so
we've got a lot of different offerings
so we're just really excited about what
we're doing now tonight we saw some
entertainment yeah talk about the
entertainment oh my gosh so skyd Mouse
who was a long time Las Vegas veteran
amazing Entertainer she has built a show
specifically for this venue we talked
about it months ago and I just told her
you know here's kind of what I'd like to
see you know I'd seen her previously yes
at different venues Cosmopolitan at the
Tropicana where she really like started
her Boom Boom Room routine yes that's
what I feel like the boom boom Vibes she
came out there in the crowd just the
energy picked up when she came out there
tonight and she knows how to capture a
crowd so that's what we wanted because
it needs to feel immersive we want we're
kind of using this line that she came up
with it's like we want you to be feel
exclusively inclusive so you're up here
you're special but you're as hard of
something you know and so she's built
that and I'm just really excited about
the cast that she's bringing there's a
full band we've got dancers there's a
beat boxer there's a tell us there's
someone playing the harp there's a tap
dancing there's just you just never know
what you're going to experience so we're
really excited about it I love it it's
especially out here Mark I mean it's
been around here the crowd is there
you've got your family yeah the family's
here tonight
this is good and the view is I mean you
can't put a price on this you cannot so
the ghost bar is open
thank you so much for having us we
appreciate it thank you I want to hang
out with those two